one of these leaks was right over the
animatronic that Aton was hiding in and
soon enough it shorted out its spring
lock mechanism according to these
vintage instructional tapes uncovered in
FNAF 3 a spring lock mechanism is a
design inside of the animatronic suit
that allows a user to pull a crank and
lock the machine parts so that the
wearer won't be ripped apart by the
gears to change the animatronics to suit
mode insert and turn firmly the hand
crank provided by the manufacturer
turning the crank will recoil and
compress the animatronic parts around
the sides of the suit providing room to
climb inside please make sure the spring
locks are fast and tight to ensure the
animatronic devices remain fixed and
whoever created the instructional tapes
seems very aware of what can happen if
the instructions are not followed please
pay close attention while learning how
to operate these suits as accidents SL
injuries SL deaths SL irreparable and
grotesque Ming can occur